olivo livre qu'est ce qu'a pensé de t t
au sur la sphère france il adapte aussi
de quoi me l'a faire prendre suite à la
ddt avec quotidien avec l'équipe de
journalistes était là-bas alors je suis
arrivé là-bas une heure après en fait
son affaire sur son rappel d'affaires
francis lalanne qui aurait un voile à
boussu un caméraman de quotidiens et a
laissé sa liste qui c'est quoi la vraie
version bas la vraie version allait
vraiment pas belle à entendre la
personne doit on entend les gens comme
toi je vais te dire quand j'ai vu c'est
francis l île aussi j'aime beaucoup la
gamme beaucoup là c'est vrai qu'ils
voient là il y des choses sur lesquelles
je suis d'accord avec lui sur rien du
tout mais là franchement je suis chez
soutenu à fond l'équipe de quotidiens
entière parce que voilà si celle ci
s'est passé ce qui s'est passé qui les a
agressés pas le cas alors c'est pas le
cas alors c'est pas le cas alors
premièrement à ce jour 1 d'ailleurs il
ya aucune vidéo qui montre qu'il ya eu
une attaque physique en forte envers le
caméraman mais son cas témoignait
d'ailleurs moi j'ai recueilli mois des
témoignages des gens qui étaient autour
c'est maintenant et c'est son témoignage
luiz alex il y était donc lé moyen âge
des journalistes de l'aps que je pense
que ça va vous entendez sur un chemin
j'ai même recueilli mois d'été mais déjà
c'est trop tôt mais ce qui est
surprenant cyril c'est qu'on a un
journaliste pour un cameraman qui dit
qui a été victime d'agressions physiques
qui sont partis et que le soir ils ont
constaté à trauma crânien et une
blessure au poignet moi tu sais cyril je
suis arrivé une heure après tout ça mais
une heure après l'équipe de quotidien
est revenu et a travaillé jusqu'à la fin
de l'après midi et j'ai même fait une
interview avec eux personne n'a été
blessé
ça traumatisme crânien parfois on peut
ne pas le sentir je te jure rôle mal au
poignet enfin poignet presque cassée
comme on a pu l'entendre
même si je me suis dit qu'est ce qui
s'est passé c'est quoi la version que
vous avez il a accepté l'interview de
quotidiens de marc lalanne
il accepte on est dehors de l'axé
l'interview dans vraiment non c'est
vraiment une terre nous caler d'avancé
juste demandé à ne pas être filmé le
même sens que l'interview départ je vais
vous expliquer pourquoi aujourd'hui ça
s'est passé mais ça va être un autre
citoyen ça aurait été la même chose
quotidien des agissements aujourd'hui
avec de la manipulation et trompe les
images et il trompe les gens qui parle
je peux vous donner une anecdote très
simple ils ont faire un reportage avec
ingrid courage que je connais très bien
qui est une chanteuse en gage
et tout au long de ce reportage ça se
passait très bien ils font des caresses
dans le dos et ce qui s'en suit et quand
ce reportage est sorti ils ont fait
passer pour la pierre qu'on cotise du
monde ils l'ont sa vie salies le
problème c'est que j'avais une
déferlante après sur les réseaux sociaux
cette femme a reçu des menaces de mort
en disant je viens de voir le reportage
sur quotidien et quelqu'un a marqué il
faut tuer cette bonne femme pascale et
dangereux grave parce qu'il ya eu une
manipulation d'imagés une manipulation
de parole voilà pourquoi quand les
équipes de quotidiens aujourd'hui se
déplace à certains endroits eh bien ils
ne sont pas acceptés et puis ça peut
monter crescendo
aujourd'hui c'est francis lalanne est ce
que malheureusement je moi je
condamnerai ce qu'a fait francis est
vrai et si lisa stelly mêmes molesté
mais je vais vous dire aujourd'hui bien
il ya un vrai truc aussi c'est que quand
quelqu'un ne veut pas parler il faut le
laisser tranquille aussi oui mais un
moment parce que quand je vais vous dire
après ça va être les escalades et oui je
vous dire qu'il va se passer des trucs
très grave et même pour la vous dire
pour l'intégrité de certains
journalistes qui vont prendre des
risques inconsidérés sur des sur des
desserts de sujets il faut leur dire si
le mec faut pas parler tu ne la
jetterait casque n'a pas encore atteint
sa maturité ou étudier parce que francis
voilà ça va pas que se termina la jolie
alors vous avez enlevé au gainage à
berlin je suis évidemment contre la
violence mais pardon mais sur ce coup-là
il cherche un peu la merde ils viennent
interview voir deux forces francis
lalanne qui n'a pas envie de se voir ici
déjà les gens ce cas là on a eu le même
problème avec gilles bien déjà avec les
personnalités qui sont dans la rue
d'accord s'ils se font emmerder et qui
finissent par bousculer n'est pas ce que
parce que ça les agace et mafia c'est
inadmissible tu peux lui dire on n'en a
pas l'habitude une fois deux fois trois
fois ci la calade comme à metz et vous
font de sous-entendus dégueulasse avec
bigard en sous-entendant qu'il a fait un
appel au meurtre et donc du bigard et
moi j'ai trouvé ça bien pour moi il
soutient ses amis comme les prédictions
gagner a dit les normes connerie mais
valence et si on gagne on prend ce qu'on
a dit
il ce personnage et vous arrêtez ça
valait l'ayatollah du covan on arrive
vite que bigard ne parlait pas de ça
s'il est utile par les badauds nettoie
johnny par les mairies et nos excuses à
celles appelant leurs organes et une
crêpe seacret biret voilà moi je sais
pas tu sais me de busan non mais de tous
les temps voit là mais c'est vrai que
l'admission mais c'est quand tu s'est
mis d'accord admissibles oui bah oui il
faut les raccourcis dégueulasse non
seulement ils interviewent le mec contre
son gré ils font des raccourcis
dégueulasse pardon mais c'est normal que
le mec pète un câble et on attend
d'avoir sauvé le discours qu'il a tapé
ou pas non non et cyril d'ailleurs si tu
veux des témoignages de gens qui sont
autour je te donnerai des numéros de
téléphone parce que avec plaisir me suis
renseigné quand même des choses je suis
jamais quelqu'un qui annonce des choses
sans même renseigné d'accord et c'est ce
que j'ai dit c'est de l'intérêt ce qui
s'est passé c'est que les journalistes
le quotidien sont arrivés et francis a
très vite compris qu'en fait il ya
encore une manipulation des images et
sade est très bien que c'est qu'ils
valaient à venir dès lors tout
simplement dit je ne veux pas être
filmés arrêter cette interview je ne
veux pas vous répondre parce qu'ils
savaient qu'ils allaient encore mélangé
les mots et les images et ils sont
restés et moi sincèrement je pense qu'il
ya eu peu je sais pas il ya eu une
bousculade où il s'est levé puis le
caméraman a peut-être trébucher ou ce
qui s'en suit ban a jamais embêté sur un
regroupement où il y avait beaucoup de
citoyens en colère des gilet jaune et ce
qui s'en suit vous savez tous très bien
que mon film beaucoup
s'il devait y avoir des images ça ferait
longtemps qu il